Just doing a quick recap of the take creation with take recorder just to make sure you're
familiar with the tool and that you have access to it in your projects.
So a take recorder enables you to quickly record and iteratively create sequences inside
of Unreal Engine.
So takes can be created for virtual cameras, body and facial performances, you can even
catch in Niagara or vehicle animation.
When it comes to vehicle animation or blueprints and more, you can have in previous courses
we referred to them as possessible actors, you could be controlling a character in a
game like situation.
Have take recorder enabled and be recording the movement, the running around, the jumping,
whatever you might be doing.
And then that bakes it down into its individual animation sequence, which can be played back.
So if you want a very game, game like feel to a performance, for example, you can record
that with a keyboard and mouse or gamepad and then play that back with the take recorder,
which is a really powerful tool.
It saves a lot of iteration time.
And then recordings can also be taken iteratively with one or multiple actors added into a sequence.
So here's a UI for the take recorder.
There is documentation on the take recorder if you'd like to get a deeper look.
But essentially, here's a high level of the user interface, which you can dig into.
And you can pause the video if you want to really figure out what each of those options
does.
Then we also have the settings here.
So you can add access to the sources by dragging from the world outliner.
So you can just drag and drop them into the take recorder, or you can use the source panel
here up here.
You can just click source from actor and then add a specific actor.
Make sure to change the record type to the appropriate settings and then select play
and then record in the take recorder.
And then recording is displayed in real time.
So when you are finished, click stop on the recording, and then that will save your animation.
So it's a pretty straightforward tool to use.
Again, we've got documentation down here.
A few notes as well is that take recorder allows users to specify which actor properties
can be recorded.
So if you've selected the meerkat as in this example, you could remove any data that you
don't necessarily need.
Again, it's sometimes good to record all the data that you're not sure you might need for
editing later down the line.
But if there's data that you just definitely don't need, sometimes it's easier to just
disable that.
So it just cleans up that sequence a little bit more and you're not dealing with as many
properties.
And then the last note is that you can record as many takes as you need by repeating the
process or using the existing take as a basic template to combine performances into that
single file and then each individual take is saved into a sub folder.
So again, documentation is there if you'd like a deeper dive on the take recorder.